we're not the first to do this it's
actually been very useful so let me
start by telling you a little bit about
multi-party number in hand I guess that
most people here when they hear
multi-party communication they think
about number on forehead communication
which is this model that's very useful
for proving circuit lower bounds for me
the motivation for thinking about number
in hand where each player has their own
input comes from distributed computing
which is my background so think of a
system with many many participants each
participant can only sense a small part
of the environment or maybe each
participant is a server in a server farm
and it gets some small chunk of data and
we want them to do something together so
obviously they're going to communicate
in order to do that these by the way are
the kilobots from Harvard so what is the
multi-party communication protocol in
this context we're going to have K
players and they each receive a private
input which only they know and the goal
is for them to compute some joint
function of their inputs and there's two
models you can think of for
communication actually there's more than
two but in general like one basic design
decision you have to make is do they
communicate by broadcast or do they
communicate by unicast so broadcast
means that when one player says
something everyone receives this and
this is nothing else in the classical
shared blackboard model and another
equally interesting setting for
distributed communication is message
passing where I have the ability to send
a private message to a participant if I
want to do it and then if I want to say
something to two different players I'm
charged for that twice but today I'm
going to focus on shared blackboard
communication where I just in charge one
time for putting my message out there
and then everyone can see it for free
and by the way later on this week
archive is going to talk about lower
bounds for the message passing models so
this is also an active area of research
why do we care so in distributed
computing what we typically care about
is how long is it going to take me to do
what I want to do so we want to lower
bound on the number of rounds this is
different from what we care about in
communication complexity which is
usually the total number of bits that
you need to solve the problem the reason
we care more about rounds than we do
about total bits is that a distributed
system often has a very large bandwidth
or capacity we have so many participants
that we can send a lot of bits in a very
short time the question is is that
enough for us to do what we want to do
so we care about rounds and the way we
model this is called the congest model
the way we introduce sort of
communication complexities we say in
every round every player is able to send
some parameter B number of bits and so
the total bandwidth of the system is
linear in the number of players right so
this is very large it's very large
bandwidth if we are able to prove a
super linear lower bound on the total
communication complexity of the task
then we get a non-trivial lower bound on
the number of realms take your
communication complexity lower bound /
it by B times K that's the lower bound
on the number of rounds but we can't
always do this sometimes there are
problems which have low communication
complexity but still there's something
inherently sequential about them so I'm
not going to talk about that at all
today except at the very end today I
will focus on proving communication
complexity lower bounds and getting
round lower bounds as a result what is
in here's the number of players yeah
case the number of players and is the
size of the input and in many of the
problems that we care about actually k
equals and your input is maybe the
communication graph or something that
you can see from the environment and it
roughly corresponds to the number of
players so think of these as being more
or less the same the exception to this
is when we talk about things like
mapreduce or very large data farm kind
of problems in there the size of the
input is going to be much much larger
than the number of participants but for
that kind of problem broadcast is not
appropriate
don't have servers that can broadcast
the message to every other server more
problems okay so having said that I'm
not going to talk anymore about the
congest model I am going to talk just
about shared blackboard the classical
communication complexity model and we'll
have a lower bound that is powerful
enough it is super linear and so we will
be able to get the round lower bound
that we want just in the side lower
bound strong lower bounds in multiparty
number in hand communication have only
started appearing in maybe the last five
years so what if we the distributed
computing community been doing before
then the answer is like a lot of other
fields in theory we're able to get a lot
of mileage out of just reductions from 2
parte communication complexity and
usually the way that you do that how you
take your system which is some
communication network you divide it into
two logical parts and you do this in
such a way that the cut connecting them
is sparse so you can't have a lot of
communication going across quickly and
then you embed some tu parte
communication problem you have Alice and
Bob each one represents one side of the
network and you argue well if this
distributed network is doing whatever I
want it to do then it's solving some
communication complexity problem and
then you're able to say we need a lot of
communication it's going across the
sparse cut so that's going to take a
long time and we have some really
beautiful lower bounds that work along
these lines the problem is what happens
if your system doesn't have these spark
sparse cuts in the system actually that
I'm talking about today shared
blackboard is a very good example of
this no matter which way you try to
slice it it has no sparse cuts so this
kind of approach is not going to get you
anywhere so you really have to talk
about the multi-party the real thing
that's going on here all right so the
problem we'll talk about today is of
course said the strainers because what
else this is a disjoint is for the
multiplayer a set up we're going to have
K input sets and we're asking is there
anything that all these sets have in
common or not I want to mention that
there is no promise here
there's a version of this that's been
studied before which does have a promise
and it has applications and streaming
but this is something different and it's
convenient to think of this in the
following way the disjoint us problem
with n elements and K players is just
the disjunction on all the elements is
it true that all the players got this
element and we'll use this
representation to sort of construct our
lower bound okay let me just give you
one example showing why said the
sternness is such a useful problem so
here's an example let's say I want to
show that computing the diameter of a
graph which I get as input is hard so
the way I'm getting these inputs is I
have my key players and each one gets
some subset of the edges in the graph
with possible duplication of edges and
what I want them to do is look at the
union of all the edges that they got and
tell me what is the diameter of the
graph induced so I want to claim that if
I can compute the diameter of a graph
with small communication then I can
solve this dryness will get the lower
bound from that the domain that will be
reducing from from for destroying us is
just the set of all possible edges all
unordered pairs a B and here's the
reduction suppose I get these sets as
inputs for destroy us we're going to
construct in our heads a graph where
each player takes the inputs edges that
it got and it puts in the graph exactly
those edges that it did not get in its
input ok and all the players do this why
did we do that right and then we can
just go and compute the diameter of this
the sets the input sets are disjoint if
and only if for every edge there is some
player that is missing this edge and
this player in this reduction is going
to put that edge in the graph ok so in
this reduction the sets are destroyed if
and only if every edge is put in by some
player which exactly means that the
graph were constructing is going to be a
click and it will have
diameter one hey if there is some edge
in the intersection nobody's going to
put it in the graph and it's going to be
missing and then the diameter will be at
least two so that's an easy reduction in
general a lot of these reductions are
this easy but I hope I've convinced you
that said the story this is a nice
problem to think about all right so what
can we say about the communication
complexity of destroyers so we have K
players and each one gets n bits of
inputs so it's trivial that you can do
this in order K n bits of communication
just write everything but it's also easy
to see that you can do better and one
way to do that is the first player is
going to go first and it will write on
the board all the elements that it
doesn't have ok so these are definitely
not in the intersection player 1 didn't
get them now we're going to move on to
the second player and it's going to add
the elements that it doesn't have but
we're not going to write anything more
than once because we're conserving on
communication and we keep going like
this until we've covered all the players
or all the coordinates appear on the
board if all the coordinates appear on
the board then there is no intersection
because we've ruled everything out and
if we've finished all the players and
there's something that doesn't appear on
the board then everyone got it so the
sets are not destroyed what's the cost
of this well every coordinate is written
on the board at most once and in
addition it could be that some players
don't have anything new to say and
they're just going to say move on so
that's another bit so the total cost is
n log n plus king much better than n
times K but in fact you can do slightly
better than even this by packing
together the cord and it's a little bit
more cleverly the way you do this is
basically you notice so let's say that
we've executed the protocol up to some
point and there's some number of
coordinates Z which we haven't ruled out
yet so these are the coordinates that
conceivably might be in the intersection
so notice that if the sets are disjoint
then every coordinate can be ruled out
by some player
right every coordinate is missing from
someone's input and that means that
there is some player that can rule out a
lot of coordinates in one shot right
total of Z is missing every coordinate
is missing from one player then some
players missing at least 0 ver que
coordinates the way will be a little bit
more efficient it's just encode these as
a batch encode these as a subset of size
0 ver que from the Z that are missing
and then you get an amortized cost of
log k / coordinate that you just ruled
out so the more efficient protocol
basically goes through all the players
if you don't have a lot to say you say
nothing just say move on if you are able
to rule out a lot of coordinates at once
then you write them as a batch and if
we've gone through all the players once
around and nobody had this many
coordinates to contribute then we are
finished do we know that the sets are
not disjoint so this protocol gets us n
log k plus K at this point we asked
ourselves all right can we do better we
know that sometimes these logs even
though they seem like they should be
there you can actually get rid of them
by being clever and my favorite example
of this is of course hast a big deal son
so if you think about just to play or
sparse said destroy nests if I'm going
to promise you that every player gets
exactly s elements you might think that
the right answer is s log n every player
needs to write these s coordinates and
it's going to take you log in bits to
encode each chord in it but they have
this really elegant randomized protocol
which actually gets you order s so this
log even though it might seem inherent
it's not can we do something like that
here and I want to remind you that in
our case this log K is the difference
between getting a lower bound and not
getting a lower bound because we need a
super linear lower bound so n log K will
in the end give you a lower bound of la
que on the number of rounds while n
gives you nothing
so actually we proved that you cannot
get rid of it we show that the
information cost of destroying us is at
least 10 log k the plus k you get very
very easily and this actually makes a
lot of sense if you think about it what
is this log k doing it's pointing to
some player this is the identity of a
player so what are lower bound shows is
that for every one of the coordinates
you must become convinced of the
identity of a player who is missing this
chord in it you must convince yourself
that it's not in the intersection
because some particular player J didn't
get it and our lower bound is very
explicit about this the proof outline
follows sort of the standard information
complexity lower balance a scheme so
remember that this Jonas is a
disjunction over conjunctions the way we
prove the lower bound is first we use
actually an existing direct some result
which says the cost of destroyed ness is
going to be n times the cost of solving
this little and in here and then we just
have to go and prove that and is not
completely trivial that solving and is
going to take log K bits of
communication so I've been saying
information and I haven't said which
what kind of information I mean the kind
of information I mean is called
conditional information costs this is
the notion introduced by bar Yosef jai
Ram Kumar into navasana in 2004 and this
is the definition so we take a
distribution that looks like this this
is my input x and i also have an
auxiliary variable D and I'm gonna
analyze what an external observer learns
from the transcript of the protocol
about the inputs of the players
condition on this auxiliary variable D
which is actually really going to be
important to you but just notice first
that if I'm able to prove a lower bound
on this then this is of course bounded
by the entropy of the
transcript so we get a communication
lower back it's good enough even though
it's a little weird and the direct some
that they showed is exactly what we need
in this context with some conditions
which will have to satisfy so we get
that if you're working with the
distribution muon a single coordinate
take the product on end coordinates this
join us is going to be n times as hard
as solving and and here are the
conditions first of all the reason we
need this auxiliary variable you better
make sure that the inputs are
independent conditioned on it so this is
a constraint we're going to have to keep
in mind the other constraint is that the
support of the distribution we're
working with had better not include any
inputs for which the end is one and this
may seem strange because if I know that
the answer is 0 then this looks like a
very easy distribution right but the
answer is actually we're looking at not
distributional costs but worst-case
costs so I'm taking a protocol which
needs to be correct with high
probability on every input even inputs
that are not in the support and we're
just analyzing it with respect to this
distribution which has this funny
property and this is very important in
order for the direct sum to go through
in general this looks like external
information external information does
not obey direct sum only internal
information does so it's this funny
trick that lets us argue by direct them
okay so i won't go through this i just
thought it might be nice for those of
you who haven't seen it but this is not
new that's just sketch of the direct
some proof but take my word that it
works what's new for our paper is
analyzing the cost of end so first let
me tell you what is the hard
distribution so let's keep in mind what
we have to satisfy first off we have to
make sure we're never going to get an
answer of one that's because we need
this for the direct Sun so to satisfy
this constraint what we're going to do
is always pick some random players II
and
give it 20 by doing this we ensure that
the answer is here what else in general
we don't want there to be a lot of zeros
because if there's many zeros it's easy
to find one so that would be making life
easy for the protocol we want to not
have it finds zeros but we do need some
zeroes right because all our analysis is
going to be conditional in this
auxiliary variable we're already saying
look players they got a zero we want to
make sure that we're left with entropy
to get the lower bound so this is how
much entropy we're going to need because
this is the lower bound that we're
proving your drank to show because if
you know what your output is zero so
what you trying to lower so this is what
I said before let me go back to the
definition I'm taking a protocol pi
which has a good worst case error on any
input it's going to give you the right
answer with probability let's say
two-thirds okay and then I am analyzing
it with respect to a distribution that
doesn't include some inputs okay yes
exactly I'm analyzing the information
cost of this protocol with respect to
this distribution but I have to assume
that it works on the all one input
otherwise I get no lower back from this
yeah so yeah so the lower bound I'm
proving here is not distributional its
worst case
alright so we said we need some zeros we
want as few zeros as possible other than
this one guy that we already gave 02
ideally you would just pick one other
player and give it 0 and then everyone
else gets one but this failed the other
criterion this wouldn't be independent
condition on the special player that got
a zero but this is easy to emulate just
instead of doing this give each player
other than the special player give them
zeros independently with probability 1
over K what we get is that the expected
number of zeros other than players II
will be 1 you really should take this to
BK minus 1 but whatever so we're
emulating this and now we get that the
inputs are independent condition on Z
art so now this is what we show that if
you take this hard distribution and
let's say you have a protocol with small
worst-case error then the transcript of
the protocol needs to leak lock a bits
of information even conditioned on the
special player who got 0 so implicitly
what I want to argue is that the
transcript of this protocol has to
reveal it has to point to a player whose
input with 0 and in general I'm going to
have two such players one of them is
going to be the special player z one of
them will be one of the other players if
I can say the transcript always outs one
of them then half the time it's not
going to be Z it's going to be the other
player and then we're going to leak log
K bits of information okay so how do I
formalize this idea of pointing what
does it mean that the transcript exposed
the player that got a zero there's
actually a nice way to formalize this
concept so I'm going to look at what
happens to the posterior probability
that this player got is 0 after seeing
the transcript and we're going to show
that often it happens that for some
player I we now believe that it got a
zero with constant probability let's say
probability one
half after I showed you the transcript
whereas before I showed you the
transcript I really didn't think that
this particular player got zero because
the prior probability was just one over
K ok so the posterior probability is
much much higher than the prior and this
is where the log K bits of information
are going to come from so let me skip
this slightly more technical way of
saying what I just said right now for
those of you who are familiar the log K
comes in because the KL divergence
between a Bernoulli random variable with
constant probability of seeing being
zero and Bernoulli one over K is exactly
log K so revealing the identity of a
player who got zero is worth log K bits
of information ok so that's it this is
the way we get this lower bound after
doing this we noticed something
interesting I think we notice that
actually external information for shared
blackboard is incompressible we know
that for two players if I give you a
protocol and it doesn't reveal a lot of
information to an external observer
about the input then you can compress
this protocol really really well to
something that's roughly the external
information that it revealed and some
poly logarithmic factors in the
communication and actually what we get
here is that the gap is much bigger is
the number of players increases so
notice that what is the information cost
of and how many bits am I revealing when
I solve and I claim that I never need to
reveal more than this log K bits of
information no matter what the
distribution is and this is easy to see
I'm just going to have a protocol where
I go through the players and they tell
me their inputs until I find a player
that got a zero and then I stopped
what's the entropy of the transcript I
can compress it to just the identity of
the first player where I stopped right
so it's just log K bits of information
and that's also the an upper bound on
the information revealed so computing
and is cheap in terms of information but
what is it in terms of communication
it's expensive and this is very easy to
see so if I take a distribution where
with probability one-half everyone gets
one and with probability one-half I'm
just going to hide 10 somewhere it's
easy to see that to solve and on this
distribution you need to find this
player who got a zero you need to
essentially go through a linear number
of players until you're convinced that
there is no such player so we get a gap
of K over a log K okay and this is not
the most convincing example in the world
because it's a small example the input
size is one bit per player maybe this
doesn't scale who is speaking at round I
like hey so this is actually very
important for our model we go with the
usual shared blackboard model which says
that the next player to speak is a
function of what's written on the board
okay so you look at the board and based
on that we need to know who goes next
you could think of other ways to define
it sort of like the more adaptive models
of communication that are used in
adversarial coding if you do that you
won't get this bigger gap but you still
are going to get a gap very likely so
this is an interesting thing to think
about yes I just wanted to say that
we're working now on generalizing this
to something that actually does scale
with the input and the answer seems to
be that it's roughly k with maybe some
poly logarithmic factors okay let me
also mention without saying much about
we know that for two players internal
information is the amortized cost of
solving many copies of one problem as
the number of copies goes to infinity
the communication for solving all of
these together the per copy cost is just
going to be exactly the internal
information what the players learn about
each other what is the situation 4shared
blackboard we don't exactly know we were
able to show that the compression part
of this so the less equal here does go
through you can compress to the external
information costs but we know that it's
not tight so actually you can sometimes
compress to better
than the external information costs so
there needs to be some intermediate
definition for reasons that I don't have
time to get into you can't just take the
2-player internal information costs and
generalize it the way you would want to
and we're trying now to figure out skip
all of this what is the right notion
what should we write here in order to
have this be tight which in some sense
is asking what is the right analog for
shannon's entropy for one-way
communication for internal information
for interactive communication how should
you generalize this to the multi-party
shared blackboard setting all right so
let me conclude here there any questions
you